this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to engineering and climate
change
EE 292 H we're excited we have really
important and exciting lectures today
guest lectures as you know purpose of
the class is to help you make a
difference but one very important simple
thing you can do today
it's easy it makes a big difference a
lot of the other things you could do or
harder here's what's ahead or what's
behind we've covered at this point most
of these topics and here is this week's
lecture linda gates and and ed Minster
they'll speak to us about green building
and kind of beyond bleed for homes
the following week Dave Duff will talk
about modular engineering electric cars
oh so much more our our logistics are as
always you can reach me my email we
start taping right about now
please use course works for homework
anybody who's having problems as always
you can go ahead and email to me don't
worry just don't worry just do the
homework and it'll all get counted there
are some great readings on the site and
some of you have taken me up it's
wonderful on suggesting terrific
readings of your own thank you I think
the best way rather than trying to weave
all of those into the lecture here I
will start posting all those on the site
so you can all get at them and see what
these extra readings are to auditors let
me know if you want me to email you that
same listing because that might be
helpful the videos of the class you know
the usual way to get it but you know
we've got a wrinkle right now so more
about that on the next page and we've
had a couple students over the last
couple weeks take us up on meeting in
bytes before class for lunch sometimes
the guest lecturer can do that more
often than not not but if I know
somebody will be there I'll be there and
it's fun if you if you can do it it's
fun so the class last week's lecture I
know I got a flood of
emails from people who couldn't do it
and my apologies what happened if you're
listening now but you you weren't there
or you couldn't hear them
we had a lecturer who gave us some
really exciting information about the
work he's doing in electric chemical
research especially going towards making
fuels it was really cool unfortunately
some of it he's in the middle of panting
and if he had said that we could go
ahead and put all that out on the web
publicly it would have blown his rights
for foreign filing that's how that works
so within Stanford it's okay but
externally it's not so for two weeks
last week and this week our entire class
has gone dark to the outside world
I'm sorry auditors and the students can
get to it by this route Michelle Lucas
tells me you just go through this route
if you're an SCPD you have a different
arrangement that you know through SCPD
but if you're a regular student in this
class full time matriculated this is
your route I will put the slides on our
course site later today so you'll be
able to catch that you don't have to
furiously write it all now if you have a
problem let me know and do catch up on
will chew is lecture this week if you
haven't already because after this week
his lecture gets pulled down off off our
site off off even this access and then
we'll go back to being public more
public more more available so and his
lecture will be gone so you've got one
more week to see his lecture and then
your homework each week and you guys are
doing great on this summarizing the
lecture by Wednesday or sometimes a day
or two later and by Sunday doing some
reading and emailing me at least one
burning question our lecturers love this
by the way they know what you're
thinking about they build part of their
talk around what on earth is it that the
students really want to know about so
keep doing that please
for next week here's some readings again
the G SEP site is a great place to find
some things about advanced trance
rotation options and about batteries
this will be great preparation for Dave
Duff's talk I've been asking for you to
suggest a reading meeting lecturer or
researcher and a lot of you have come
through and done that as I say I'll
compile that on the course work site
that's fantastic you're making us all
better informed I love that
did anybody decide to take me up on this
offer this invitation to do a quick term
project this is the right place in the
quarter to think about that before that
end of the quarter madness anybody just
dying to get up here and talk for two or
three minutes about something you
passionately care about in climate okay
fine I understand overload it's too bad
though it would be neat okay I will not
ask again I will stop being boring on
that but you'd have fun okay
next week our lecturer Dave Duff and he
also worked at Parc before he worked at
Tesla Motors so right now he's the
senior mechanical engineer at Tesla
Motors he is or a senior mechanical
engineer he his job is to obsess about
connections to batteries that is his
chop he does it well he has a more
varied past at Parc and some of what he
talked about last year included modular
engineering and including new printing
processes for solar cell grid lines
which sounds interesting
his goal really is to build cool stuff
and that's what he does so anybody
mechanically inclined you know when
you're putting together your questions
you can include be nice if it's
environment related but you can
certainly include knowing that that's
his is his place of joy and he would
delight to tell you all about that as
usual we've got our information
opportunities Stanford nearby the thing
to highlight here is that the clean tech
open is this week so if you're
interested in going this is the time to
know Rex was saying that you could get a
discount to go that the students could
get a discount but time is growing short
and now without further
do we're going to introduce this week's
sorry
this week's yes lectures Linda and Ann
and this is a phenomenal project I'll be
interested to hear what you think about
this as a field trip versus this as a
classroom lecture we've done this twice
as a field trip
the logistics become tough because then
we need to find it basically a
three-hour window for everybody to be
able to get off campus there and come
back but it's been wonderful as well you
can see this this beautiful model that
they had of what they were doing and
they have really tried to hit a number
of important areas in building not just
the materials and the design and the eco
sensibility of energy consumption but
water I'm continuing to be struck by
using every drop four times and so
there's going to be a lot to learn here
let's welcome our guests hello everybody
I'm going to try to get this on and see
if this works all right turn this show
don't worry about me
should be doing beautiful how did you
know I did I hit escape and then I hit
oh you rock
perfect great alright well welcome we're
thrilled to see all of you as Leslie
said I'm Linda Yates
and the homeowner not that home and this
is an ed minster and we like to describe
and as our green goddess or our guru of
green or our den mother of green we
founded if I go back Tom Allah is what
we call the project I'll give you a
little history we're going to what we're
going to walk through the this
presentation fairly quickly again
normally when we do this we do this
on-site at the house walking through
where you can touch and see it it's a
really 3d experience I will tell all of
you that on November 16th I don't know
if any of you know this but the US Green
Business Council which obviously owns
the whole lead standards of which and
actually was the co-chair of the
development of all of the lead for home
standards so if anything you want to
know about lead and is is really the
Guru on that topic as it moved from lead
new construction which is really
targeted towards commercial to lead for
homes but the u.s. GBC has Greenville's
so any of you who are interested in
green building ought to go take a tour
up to San Francisco because their
international conference is being held
in San Francisco this year the 14 15 and
16 and on 16th our house is going to be
a featured tour and I think it runs from
2:30 to they'll be on-site from 3 to 5
they'll be on-site from 3 to 5 any of
you who would
she liked to tag on to that tour after
this and come see it for real you're
more than welcome you're also more than
welcome at anytime to email any of us
because we're one of these people where
you'll you'll see that the home is
really meant to be a gathering place and
so for instance right now I'm mentoring
the Solar Decathlon team at Stanford
it's the first I don't know if any of
you have are familiar with it but those
guys have been at the house a lot and
it's one of these things where once you
come you're part of the family we're
like the Hotel California you can check
in but you can never leave so you're
welcome anytime the more the merrier so
let's talk a little bit about where this
happens because it's not just about
green building it's it's about place and
it's about people so the property in
Portola Valley where we built is
actually where I grew up my parents
bought the place in 1967 this is the
original house that was on the property
it was actually built as a spec house
and by the time we bought it from my
parents who moved about a mile away it
literally disappeared so uh-huh yeah
this is not what's up okay yeah exactly
so when my so historically my husband
and I have done a lot of stuff our
backgrounds actually are not in green
building I did Investment Banking and
then I did management could explode
strategy consulting all over the world
and but philanthropic aliy our huge
passion is the environment climate
change biodiversity EO Wilson is a huge
hero of mine conservation wildlife and
so when we decided that we were going to
take it we need to take the house down
what we decided we wanted to do was to
really put our money where our mouth was
if you will and build hopefully would be
the greenest house in America we
actually say it's the greenest house in
its class because the greenest house
would be actually be a yurt or a tent it
would not be what we built but we wanted
to do it as a demonstration site to
really showcase what was possible in
green building and to do a lot of other
things which we'll talk about so that's
really where we started and this is
actually
why this is not going to be functional
that it has to actually work hmm all
right let's see all right any other idea
all right great
so obviously we talked about kind of
that we're happiest when we're hiking so
build us a tent and we'd be happy so
these are actually some of the images
that the architects started with but I'm
gonna let Anne say a couple of seconds
about so why why even should we be
building green hands
oh well Linda's got the stats up there
but and you guys probably know that I
imagine Leslie's talk to you a lot about
the fact that buildings are responsible
for a huge amount of the environmental
impacts globally so and then we break
that down by non-residential buildings
residential buildings new construction
existing construction the construction
process itself and then operations and
maintenance so there are many aspects to
this we also look at transportation
impacts associated with our use of
buildings and our choice of building
sites so when we look at through all
those different lenses at building
impacts we start to realize that
buildings and the way we use them have a
very very large role in our overall
impact picture and climate change
particular so yeah and I mean it's it's
interesting I mean the largest Leslie
mentioned water but the largest consumer
electricity in any municipality is
actually water so it's a it's really
interesting to see kind of what the
major impacts are so when we one of the
things that's really important about
green building and if any of you end up
being architects or any of you end up
going and building something yourself or
think about even if it's if it's
remodeling an apartment or building a
house or doing whatever you really the
place you have to start is with the
people you have to start with what you
care about with what your values are and
it's not just about building a structure
because if you just build a structure
then what you end up with is something
has no meaning has no life has no
imagination and so really so Paul my
husband Paul Holland who's our
foundation capital he's unfortunately he
would love to be here today but he's in
fact he's kind of doing another talk for
the at the World Bank on just this topic
but we actually went away and said okay
we're gonna start with themes what do we
want the house to be what do we want it
to feel like what do we want it to do
and so we started with six themes the
first was a gathering place so in my
family
I'm goes to five policy Young's to four
everything we do is large and crazy we
do nothing small and intimate you have
to go to somebody else's house for that
that's what I think I'm kidding when I
say you're all invited it's completely
true ask Ann she's been there a thousand
times we've had tons and tons of events
so again we wanted to make it a
demonstration site and we wanted to have
it be a place where we could hold events
that would have impact so whether it is
supporting people that hopefully you
will vote for today or it is supporting
or if it is we hosted an event for Amory
Lovins do any of you guys know who Amory
Lovins is rocking Mountain Institute the
very first event we hosted was a salon
for him with 200 people trying to raise
funds for Rocky Mountain Institute the
sustainable silicon valley which is a
consortium of businesses and
municipalities we hosted an event for
them there were five mayor's looking at
Green Building Code who are in that at
that event so one of the things that
will get a ding on in the house is it's
not 2,500 square feet and and we'll talk
about that if a house is bigger than
2,500 square feet you actually lose
points you start in the hole for every
100 feet you are over over 2,500 square
feet so a gathering place that will come
back up was was was number one secondly
outside in so as we as I said we're
happiest when were hiking we said build
us a tent we'll be happy if you come and
you see the house it has a lot more
impact than than me just talking about
outside in but the goal is it's all one
story not only you know more than 5 feet
from being able to see outside your no
more than 5 feet from you'll get outside
so there's a lot of
movement and out it also has a huge
impact on the concept of integrated
design because you can't really have a
house that's outside in if you start
with an architect and then two years
later you bring in a landscape architect
so this whole concept integrated design
which and I'll talk about in a second is
a big is a big deal the global
sensibility so Poe and I have been
really blessed we've traveled around the
world we lived in Amsterdam for almost
three years the idea here was look we do
not want to have anything that was strip
mined in somebody else's backyard
we don't want chemicals that were made
someplace else we don't want copper
that's leeching into off a roof into the
microbial soils that will then have an
impact on people going forward
multi-generational was really look there
are castles that are built and built
that have existed for a thousand years
we build houses for twenty five and not
only do we build houses for 25 years we
build for dwelling places for every one
person just imagine the amount of
embodied energy that goes into all of
those dwelling places so our goal was
really two things one is to utilize the
elements of universal design so that you
could have a place that people could be
comfortable and safe from two years old
to 200 years old and multi-generational
also meant that something that it would
last forever
and what that in terms of both kind of
the durability aspects of it but also in
terms of the aesthetics so it's very
simple aesthetics because if you have an
avocado green house that was great in
the 70s and it's built for a hundred
years but in the 80s everybody hates it
then they pull that down and then then
you've basically destroyed that and then
obviously a sense of soul was a big deal
for us our goal was to have it be
inspirational and not intimidating and
the biggest piece and this is what we're
going to go into obviously is the
environmentally regenerative piece so
I'm just going to skip through these
just because I don't want to take up a
lot of time because we want to spend a
lot of time working in QA with you guys
so the obviously the main part of what
Ann and I want to talk about today is
this whole concept of being
environmentally regenerative so what
does that mean to you guys what would
what is the concept you hear the word
green you hear the word sustainable you
hear
the word regenerative what does that
mean anything to you guys and if it does
kind of just shout out what it is that
you think environmentally regenerative
would mean no way no wait no wait
they're kind of like cradle to cradle
whatever you use it eventually goes back
and exactly the same quality yep cradle
to cradle is a great example bill
McDonough was one of our very first kind
of inspirations we were at a TED
conference and when we were way before
we ever started about thinking about
building green and we heard Bill talk
and then we went back the next year and
he talked again and we thought hmm this
is we were now at that point so he was
pretty inspirational in that whole
concept of the cradle to cradle any
other thoughts any thoughts about what
the heats a waste you named one of them
there's really five key elements around
in the in the concept of green building
that an and the gurus that we we brought
on board really taught us about what do
you think the five areas waste being one
of them what would be for others that
you would think of energy yep and by the
way energy trumps everything
water waste you hmm
Vangie yep habit out and then there's
one more air quality indoor air quality
is a key piece of it it's it's how would
you build in the way we looked at it its
occupant health and well-being right
yeah
and then so the last one is really is
materials so we really looked at all
five of those things energy water waste
materials and habitat and our goal
really there's actually up here
afterwards if anybody wants to see it
we actually have aerial photos back to
1949 of the site and we actually brought
in five field biologists to help us look
at the site and to chronicle the native
flora in the native fauna and our goal
was really to really turn the slides
green so that they would look great
was really to help restore the land as
if it were 200 years ago so the name
because we don't want it to be about us
it's really about no house can make a
difference it's just we hope that it'll
be a pebble in the pond and have a
ripple effect tamil law is actually the
Ohlone word for mountain lion mountain
lions are the largest mammals that still
exist other than humans in Portola
Valley and are it's really us paying
homage to those people who frankly
stewarded the land much better than any
of us ever can or ever will but this
gives you a sense of this is 1949 and
then this was in 2000 I think this is
2005 you can just see how different the
land was it was originally basically oak
savannah but then as more more people
moved in and planted non-natives you
could see that that growing up the
change is taking place okay so now we're
going to get into what are kind of the
green goals and features of so when we
got started there are a couple of
overarching themes that we were trying
to do and then we're gonna get into the
details of the energy water waste
materials habitat the first is that we
were really trying to debunk the myths
of green building and there are three
primary myths one is that there it's
ugly and you have to live in a concrete
box with no windows well you're lucky
because you guys are at Stanford and
there are a lot of green buildings
regenerative buildings that are on
Stanford that aren't ugly and aren't
concrete boxes but that really is one of
the big myths that you'll hear from
people the second is that you have to
drastically change your lifestyle and in
fact if the questions that you sent us
are those people in this room or those
people across ok ok great
so there are some really great questions
in there and we'll we'll do the Q&A
afterwards but but one of the questions
a couple of questions touched on well
how much do you guys have to really
drastically change your lifestyle I
think the beauty of green building now
is that it is fundamentally different
and you don't have to if you if you do a
lot of the integrated design work that
we did you don't have to drastically
change your lifestyle and then the third
myth is that it's twice as expensive so
green building is all about building in
general is all about your tastes and
what kind of materials that you want or
what you want it to look like or what
size it is etc the increase do
Green Building is really only two to
five percent and I'll leave I'll give
you an equation that Amory Lovins shared
with me which is why this is true so
there's really four you have to
calculate four things one is what are
those things that you're going to do
because you are building green that you
wouldn't otherwise do so putting on
solar panels but of course now we've
moved from solar panels to solar power
so even that isn't isn't a cash capital
cost so there are those those things
that you're going to do and that you
wouldn't otherwise do but then you have
to subtract from that those things that
you would do if you if you that you
don't have to do because you're building
green so for instance you we don't have
any HVAC we don't have all this ducting
all over the place so that's this that
is something you have to subtract out
the third is there are those things that
you're going to put in that you're going
to put a greener a greener version of so
you're putting windows in anyway you're
just going to put a greener version of
those windows in and right now until we
get to scale economies there are some of
those things are more expensive and then
the fourth thing or the operating costs
which you have basically zero operating
costs we used almost no heat one of
Emory Avery's challenges to us was to
use basically was to design a house that
not only doesn't use no air conditioning
which of course you know in this area
you don't need Louise no heat so that's
it that's a big deal
and so really right now for our project
the increased due to green building was
really about two to five percent sensor
because you're doing all this having
environmental consultants come in and
you know I imagine you're doing a lot
more of the pre building you know
thinking and in inspection than most
other buildings and that didn't add to
your concept is affiliate observation
and we do disconnect those two things so
there are the there is the design there
are the design costs that we made the
conscious choice to boil the ocean I
mean it took us six months to design the
floor because we tried all sorts of
different things and we had warm floors
who wouldn't disclose what the glues
were in its
so yes but I don't think we don't really
count that because for the most part
most people we're now at a point in
history where you don't have to do all
the things that we did right remember we
started 2008 we started designing we
broke ground in 2010 and then moved in
July of 2012 the world has come and just
even in five years a long way and we
really were trying to boil the ocean in
a way that most people don't have to do
because we wanted to use it as a
demonstration site yeah that one thing
to keep in mind is there's building
there's green building and then there's
prototyping and in prototyping nobody
expects that to be at the same cost as a
steady state type of you know normal
production process whether we're talking
about widgets you know silicon chips or
houses so this was definitely
prototyping right so debunking the myths
was the first kind of global goal I mean
let Ann talk a little bit about the
second was demonstrating the power of
integrated design yeah so first of all
if you guys heard the term integrated
design one or two of you okay so do you
have a sense of what that means aspects
of how the building is going to be used
in future and edition churches that's
part of it
other thoughts about integrated design
what are we integrating all the systems
of the building all the SIS
and how does that happen so you don't
just look at the windows by themselves
then look at the HVAC system you look at
the windows and the HVAC yeah so who's
doing that not just all the contractors
but all the design team and the
contractors so there's they're actually
two terms that we play with one is
integrated design and one is integrated
project delivery now there's a really
important distinction between these two
and you can probably guess from the
terms what's the difference in a great
design integrated project delivery
right one is all about design and those
of us in the design community you guys
are you're all gonna be engineers right
it's all about design right well no the
thing has to get built and so the
progression from thinking integrated
design will solve our all our problems
to the recognition that oh right then
there's all the stuff that happens after
design and in reality we find we need
construction intelligence and insight
during design we also need design
intelligence and insight during
construction because much as we would
like to believe that the design is
complete when the shovel hits the soil
it's not those six months on the floor
that was after construction started when
we kind of went you know there are one
or two issues here that we haven't quite
worked through and is that the exception
or is it the rule it's the rule yeah
absolutely this is real life and that is
as much as we try to commit the design
to paper these two dimensional objects
do a rather incomplete job of conveying
the three-dimensional reality and the
process by which the three-dimensional
reality comes into being so we were
progressing in our understanding about
this and our treatment of it and there
are a couple of really important things
I think again first this distinction is
no it's not all about design and we need
everyone involved right down to the
trades people who are going to be
executing the effort because we if we
don't understand we don't have the
benefit of what they know then we can't
create intelligent designs our designs
and this is where the classic conflict
between the architect and you know
general contractor come about oh those
architects they don't know anything
they're completely impractical and
frankly you engineers are much better
and then the other side of though those
contractors they're just you know a
bunch of you
knuckle-draggers and what do they know
anyway I've been dealing with this for
35 years and you're both right we all
need to listen to each other more
effectively so the other so the key
pieces people but what's really
interesting about this too and something
that I've been thinking about more and
more over the last couple of years is
that when I come in and I work with
project teams and usually they are very
design focused initially later move into
construction there is this immediate
focus on the artifact what do we have to
do to this this house to make it green
you know what we're going to do to this
what kind of mechanical system are we
going to put in it you know what are we
what are gonna make the floor of how are
we gonna frame it you know what's what
is going to be that system that provides
the good indoor air quality this is all
about the artifact but the reality is
that in order for us to produce this
artifact what needs to happen first
imagine you guys have all been out in
practice for ten years and somebody
comes in and says we're going to do the
greenest project we've ever done what's
the first thing you need to do how many
of you have taken classes in a new
school
so so what do you need - just your next
class so I'm thinking the human centered
design gap
empathize yep that doesn't hurt
what what is a result of empathizing
right so thinking what happens that's
there's a word for that I'll give you a
hint it starts with L and it's not loser
what happens what are you doing you're
in school right now what are you doing
here learning right learning right okay
so in order to produce this new artifact
that's greener than one you've ever done
before you need to learn something new
because you've been engaged in practice
for how many years and you know how to
do it well guess what you don't know
anymore you don't know how to do it you
don't know who to do it with and you
don't know what to do it with so green
building is fundamentally is about
change so you need to learn how to be
effective agents for change that is your
first job in green building an
integrated design integrated project
delivery means working with your
colleagues in a way you have never
worked with them before and you don't
know how to do it you don't know what
that process looks and that's why it's a
metaphor green building is really a
metaphor for a lot of the stuff that you
guys are doing in terms of product
design engineering it's all about
collaboration it's about
multidisciplinary actions coming
together there's really no you could
care less about green building and it
would be an incredible metaphor for what
you guys are all doing here at Stanford
in general and in whatever life you're
you're you're headed towards it really
is the concept of integrated design
multidisciplinary approaches problem
solving critical thinking human centered
design empathizing yeah I saw a survey
on LinkedIn the other day and it was how
are you involved in using collaboration
fools online so I answered the survey
and then a few days later because I
participate in a survey I got the
response back and it said only 36% of
respondents were involved in using
online collaboration tools well with
your era it's gonna be a hundred percent
and this is one of the things that we
are learning is we need to collaborate
more effectively so so we'll come back
on debunking the myths integrated design
the third was obviously earning
certifications for credibility to raise
awareness so again we call the house of
beyond lead house we were not interested
in using a bunch of checklists I have
another binder here that does have all
the checklists for those of you who are
interested in seeing them there's lead
there's a build at green which is green
point rated there's the the one that we
really use is that one how many of you
have heard of Living Building Challenge
so Living Building Challenge is actually
much harder than lead and that's really
what we used as the core there are a lot
of people and there's a lot of questions
we're going to come back to your
questions on the checklist and whether
or not LEED is actually credible or not
credible is it too easy what's the story
here was our decision and there are
actually buildings on campus at Stanford
and Stanford has said they don't really
believe in lead and there are a lot of
people who are critical of lead here was
our logic and why we actually were
trying to support a lot of these
different checklists because we are eco
geeks
we're totally willing to kind of boil
the ocean there are a lot of people who
aren't who need something to hang on to
and that's what these checklists do
these checklists it mean that at least
the people who have the right intentions
but might not have the inclination to
really go deep and go do that all their
own research have something to hang on
to so what we want to do is use them and
push them and get lead to be better and
the only way you can do that is if you
if you actually leverage them Living
Building Challenge is interesting it's
it's new it sits on top a LEED why
Living Building Challenge is important
is because they actually have a set of
red listed items so where as lead you
can use things like ice anine which is
the blow in iPhone spray phone
you can't use that for if you're are
going for a living Building Challenge
because it's made with halogenated flame
retardants so we had to go out and find
an insulation that wasn't made with
halogenated flame retardants oh by the
way we had an added benefit because that
insulation if they deconstruct the house
the ice means sticks to everything so
it's a lot more labor-intensive to try
to reuse if somebody ever took our house
down whereas the other stuff is a blown
in it's like a fiberglass but it it
feels more like cotton again if you come
to the house I've got whole bales of the
stuff that all that I'm happy to let you
do so the so that was the third big the
third big area the ok tome that this is
really screwy here it works fine
everywhere else
I love the magic man who comes from the
outside what is it all right ok so
here's another huge thing that we really
care about one of our big overarching
goals is to help create a market for
green goods there are eight different
startups that are represented in the
house and again if you're there you'll
see it clean tech is not dead ok despite
Solyndra despite what the media said it
is not dead it is still an incredible
opportunity for all of you guys to
pursue ok so we basically have Sun run
did our solar that's this whole movement
the shift from solar power from solar
panels to solar power right which is
removing the cost completely there's no
cash down there's no more excuse I don't
know if you guys know the statistic but
the Sun sends to the earth in a single
day enough energy to power the whole
world for a year our problem is not
energy it's the storage of energy so if
you really want to make a billion
dollars go out and figure out how to how
to do it in something other than lead
acid batteries so SunRun but there's and
there's more out there but Sun runs the
most successful zakat o is the light
produces the light engines we have no
incandescent in the house 100% leds or
cfls serious energy produced the windows
we have serious windows again you
you can see those Cal star products
Green cement company they do bricks and
pavers etc the does anybody know what
the the production of cement is
represents X percent of the carbon
emissions in the world do you know what
that number is 8 percent 8 8 percent 8
percent of carbon emissions in the
production of congress of portland
cement
it's outrageous we have six 50 to 80 50
to 70% of our the concrete that is in
our house is offset with slag and fly
ash Silver Spring networks is hopefully
you guys will have heard about Silver
Spring but they do the smart meters tygo
is provides energy boost it's an
efficiency booster for the solar panels
and then controlled for is the control
for is the dashboard for the house the
other one which is an older company but
is very interesting is this company
Delta Blue Grass so one of the things we
asked is okay if you can do a native
grass sod why can't you do a native
grass ass native grass sod roof why
can't you do a native grass landscape
and the reason is because native grasses
are really woody and so if you have kids
and you run across them they're not very
comfortable to run across but it turns
out that the California Department of
Transportation at Pala for Nia
Department of Water because they're all
concerned about water more than energy
have been contract growing so we joined
with them and helped fund the R&D for a
native grass sod there's now four mixes
it's 80 percent less water and no
chemicals so that's another one of the
the startups and great on bare feet
Linda while you're there do you want to
address some of the questions about
smart homes do you want it yeah we're
almost done so I think we should okay
okay let's go through this and I swear
this is like so bizarre wises
well and then one of the other big
things was greening the construction
process any and you want to touch on
that
okay sure what do you have up there just
constructing and the offices yes so
there was an existing house and I think
something like 97% of that house was
taken apart and reused in some fashion
some small fraction was recycled a lot
of it was used on site in various ways
and I think you know one of the big
stories too was relates to the Portland
cement there was a really interesting
process that we went through to analyse
how to design the foundation so as to
use the least amount of energy and
produce the least amount of carbon and
our structural engineer initially had a
foundation system in mind and design and
then later said you know there was more
hauling of soil involved in that process
than the alternative and so he revisited
that question and when he took into
account all of the hauling of soil
turned out that the other foundation
design was more resource conserving
overall so there were a lot of different
things that we looked at yeah and the
mention of no copper well we've got
copper we don't have PVC and only have
copper and wiring in the wiring right
yes so and PEX how did you guys know
what pecs is cross-linked polyethylene
it's a type of flexible supply piping
for water and it's it was the subject of
one of several really interesting
studies that the US Green Building
Council did a number of years back when
there was some pressure to prohibit the
use of PVC in lead buildings and
ultimately they decided they couldn't do
that because when you looked at the use
of PVC in terms of specific applications
in some applications it was less bad
than some of the other options in other
cases it was worse and so they went well
you know we have to really think in
terms of what application and
fresh water supply packs however was
superior to all the other options that
was another one of the analyses that we
went through so yeah cut and fill yeah
all pretty much every product was looked
at through the lens of is there an
environmentally preferable alternative
to this product and that occurred
throughout design and all the way
through construction so extractable
issue and effects what do you mean by
the extractable issue that's you
originally had extractable chemicals
that got into your water oh well yeah
there's I'm pretty sure that's been
resolved because for a while it was
approved by the state of California then
they withdrew that approval and it has
now been approved again so well it
actually it ended up being I mean
truthfully this is where politics comes
into it so there was there was a lot of
pushback from the pipe fitters union
because you don't need pipe fitters you
do for copper but you don't firth at
there's also was a lot of conversation
about because when you you look in a
traditional house you have copper and
copper then going into PVC and there's
some question about actually the copper
in the PVC when you had hot water the
the chemical reaction between those two
and what that was creating and I think
with the PAC's the issue was somewhat
about would it you do have to protect
the pecs because so we don't have it
could because it's subject to
susceptible to UV so but all of ours is
buried or in the in the walls so similar
to pax when I built my house and I end
up having to put very large carbon
filters hmm to take those extractables
out so didn't taste like plastic water
so was it
but was it cross-linked polyethylene or
was it a predecessor
I believe because the cross linking is
the thing is out extremely stable
right and that's been and we looked at
we did a lot so steady testing yeah and
you know I think to Linda's point too
about the politics the fact that the
state of California has scrutinized it
very heavily in large part due to
pressure from the labor community means
that if it gets through we have probably
the most stringent consumer laws
anywhere in the country so personally
I'm pretty much at rest with this issue
so we're just going to hit these five
things and we're gonna go into QA so
really there's five key areas we talked
about so those that we just shared with
you were kind of the overarching big
picture things that we were going for
these are specific goals within the five
areas of energy water waste material
habitat energy number one it's a net
zero energy net carbon house so it's a
we in essence we have it's also a fossil
fuel free house we don't even have
natural gas pipe down to the site with
green building obviously your biggest
thing is reduce reduce reduce reduce and
then power whatever you do have left in
terms of a need for energy with an
alternative source so for us we in
essence have geothermal is one source of
the alternative energy and solar is the
other source and the house has well I'll
just go the next page if it's got the
solar but we've got so the so net your
energy fossil fuel free and that
includes all of our transportation so
one of the things is so we have solar
here and here that's all we need to
power the house but we actually have
enough solar we think we're the first
house well we haven't found any other is
that the first house in the u.s. that
actually took into consideration putting
enough solar on to power five electric
vehicles now our oldest child is only 13
we don't have five vehicles and we
we don't have five electric vehicles so
what we did is we went ahead and put all
the solar on anyway so it's actually 118
panels 21 kilowatts of power we put it
on because it allowed us to then offset
any of the carbon from the actual
construction and it's allowing us to
bank the carbon credits for our
lifestyle and so we believe that because
our kids are young that will because
we're giving all this free energy to
PG&E now that in essence we'll have
built up a big enough bank to offset the
carbon of our entire lifestyle did you
talk with the utility just to talk with
PG&E about the effects on your local
infrastructure for having that much
solar feeding back what do you mean the
effects like your substations and yeah
it's not it's not that's it's not enough
to impact it's not enough to have to
have them create more substations or
rite-aid
but unless you mean helping them no I
just I mean I don't know that much about
it I just would be a little concerned
because I've heard that you know in the
neighborhood it
several people plug their electric
vehicles and you know that's gonna pull
too much power one way and I would
imagine that if you're having a really
sunny day you're producing so much power
that maybe they haven't taken that into
account for their already built
infrastructure I'm gonna do any concern
to you them yeah I haven't heard
anything
are you paying they're intimately
involved in this whole production yeah
and they want this is this is their
ideal when Schwarzenegger signed the a
million solar homes initiative that with
a million solar homes in the state of
California we're an end of energy
independent state
so PG&E is bring it on yeah and and
there's generally the concerns that are
expressed about the grid and electric
homes and electric vehicles doesn't
really relate so much to the supply
nobody's worried about an access what
they're worried about is the timing of
the supply versus demand piece and so
essentially they're being somewhat
cautious in terms of you know how much
they want to see the adoption rate go up
how quickly they want to see it go up
because they actually don't under
stand what the full impacts are going to
be on the grid as we go to an electric
vehicle adoption because of course all
the input comes during the day and then
the usage is spread out throughout 24
hours so it's a little dicey yes unless
the load
draws that much power whatever how much
power you put in here it won't go that
somebody has to actually draw it
yeah there
no but PG&E obviously PG&E is intimately
involved there there especially with any
of these these green houses that are
putting a lot of load on because they
want to learn from it so they've been we
actually have people at the executive
level at PG&E who have been monitoring
our house again as a demonstration site
so they have no challenges at all in
fact they love it because they think
we're energy philanthropist because they
don't pay us for the extra energy that
we're producing so more things on energy
obviously we have the wireless the AV
control system for those of you who
asked about the monitoring and the
management this is kind of a lot of
control for really handles all of that
on the lighting we use no lights unless
it's dark if you come to our house
you'll see it's all glazing we use a
hundred percent LED or CFLs and one of
the coolest things is that we use even
with all the lights fully on we use one
less than one watt per square foot the
materials there's only four materials in
the house it's very simple it's wood
there are five species of F there's no
sources of wood there's only three five
species of FSC certified wood recycled
or reclaimed wood which is the barn wood
that's on the floor and then salvaged
wood and there's there's we're trying to
demonstrate good Salvage versus bad
Salvage so good Salvage is there's a
freeway going in instead of just
mulching it up there are people that'll
take it off they'll they'll take big
pieces of it and they'll save it versus
bad Salvage which is you take a giant
redwood out of the ecosystem which can
house up to a billion organisms so we
want to try to avoid that type of that
type of salvage metal we use all
recycled metal it's it's harder to
show this when we're here one of our
goals with stone was we use no newly
quarried stone so the stone is these are
out of the bone pile in Texas it wasn't
good enough for somebody else's job or
this we have this big stone on site that
was actually quarried 50 years ago for a
building in a stadium there's 40 acres
of it that never got built and the one
thing is is you can't put it back so it
really is trying to demonstrate how much
waste there is in the green building and
then obviously glass it's all recycled
again no no painted surfaces we use we
in a couple of places where we have
color again one of our big things is as
a demonstration site we're trying to we
tried to showcase things that even
though it didn't really matter for us we
were happy to live in a tall wood house
with no stain or color or anything but
other people might want color so we
wanted to showcase a way to have color
in a sustainable way in a house so we
used plaster with integrated color same
thing with air conditioning we don't
need air conditioning but we have
radiant heating which can also do
radiant cooling and water and you want
to talk about water so yeah Linda
mentioned earlier the the large energy
burden that water represents does
anybody know what percentage of the
state's energy is used in some way shape
or form related to water one digit two
digits
it's actually 19 but it's a big number
it's a really big number and so
obviously a relatively small fraction of
that is actually related to residential
youths nevertheless we're we're
concerned about water for waters sake as
well as for the sake of energy and so we
look at both and so one of the very very
unusual aspects of this project is that
all of the grey and black water is
captured and treated and used on fight
so and this is Linda could probably
speak to the bureaucratic battles
associated with that process at great
length it is not used for potable use
although it is of potable quality but
because of various health regulations
we're restricted to using it primarily
for subsurface irrigation could have
been used for toilet flushing but the
extra material the embodied energy that
would have gone into a secondary system
for flushing toilets with the water made
no sense in a system where all the water
was already being captured processed and
reused and I'm a key person in it in
case that toddler drinks out of that
toilet so it wasn't worth it right
seriously why they yeah the embodied
energy right and the other chemical
inputs and so it's like one of those on
balance you know the conventional wisdom
is oh well you should definitely use
grey water for flushing toilets well you
know this and it's also a great
illustration how every project that's
kind of where Linda started that you you
start from your own agenda and your
priorities themes however you want to
apply them and so for example the story
about the six-month floor design project
arose out of the fact that two of
Linda's kids have respiratory issues and
so there was a desire to have zero
chemicals of any dubious nature in the
house and the sort of normal approach to
doing radiant floor system
uses composite engineered wood panels
that the radiant tubes are embedded in
well turns out those engineered wood
panels have questionable chemicals in
them and the very very typical Dodge
that you get from product manufacturers
is when you ask so what is in that
product and they say give you a very
detailed sheet five six eight pages of
fine print on an MSDS material safety
data sheet do you guys familiar with
those if you run across them yet okay
but somewhere in the fine print you'll
see X percent proprietary product you
say so
that porous product what is that may say
oh we can't tell you that it's like well
sorry we can't buy it so anyway that was
what drove the floor system that's what
drove things like no we're not gonna use
grey water to flush the toilets with and
end up with chlorine in the system which
has some adverse health concerns so one
of the things that Leslie talked about
it that she learned from another thing
is that we had a permaculturist work
with us and the goal is really repurpose
a drop of water four times so again I've
got pictures up here if anybody wants
them but this is actually the picture we
have a fifty thousand gallon cistern we
actually designed the house is a
one-story house with a steel roof the
steel roof is made of 95% eighty-five
percent recycled material and it's a
hundred percent recyclable on the back
end and it's a hundred-year roof with no
maintenance so for my durability is a
big deal in green building as well so
this is actually part of the the gray
water and black water but this it looks
like an ICBM missile seriously it's it's
it's huge you can't it's buried now but
we had actually become the municipal
water source in an earthquake so we we
are across the street from the San
Andreas so water is a big deal obviously
we use all the normal things low-flow
toilets low-flow low-flow everything
great escape oh no why and it works for
you oh my god likes me sorry guys I
don't this is never this is
something about this system because it
doesn't I've done this a thousand times
a rescue I never done so where are you
what are you hit it just yeah okay so
the other thing there's the sister in
there so again obviously the hole in the
landscape is also completely native so
as we talked about we use Delta
bluegrass we use the native grasses in
addition back in behind the house we've
actually gone as far back as when the
Ohlone were here and we've used we've
used a metal restoration consultant to
try to actually restore that meadow as
if it were 200 years ago so the other
things are native to California but
those grasses are actually native to the
site waste we talked about obviously we
have recycling we have composting
on-site we do have chickens so you can
come see our chicken and and and talked
about that a hundred percent of the
waste water the habitat is the only
other thing I'll say about habitat which
is cool is that
we have five field biologists as I said
they Chronicle then you can see it here
all the native flora all the native
fauna and then they cross-reference the
habitat value of the native flora for
the native fun of to actually create our
landscape because we wanted to invite
the let the wildlife in so we're
studying bats amphibians mammals birds
and reptiles and we have bogs that are
in essence supporting wildlife on-site
that are around the pool and so we're
studied it before we studied it during
construction and we're going to do a
ten-year longitudinal study so one of
the things that we're trying to do is
actually do what we said we're going to
do and make sure that the house is
actually operating accordingly so these
are all biofilter they're obviously
we've gotten a lot of visibility which
has been great but our real goal here is
for it to have an impact and for people
to learn from it and to give it away so
we've had as we say we've hosted tons of
events we've had field trips
there's I've taught guest lectured on
site again for STS and some other places
at Stanford besides the Graduate School
of Engineering because it really doesn't
matter right that one house is
gonna matter unless hopefully you guys
take something you learn something and
you do do something with with the
knowledge or you share it with someone
else or you can our kids founded a
organization called the earth savers
Club for kids you can go to their
website and give it to little kids that
you know so really it's it's more about
kind of what what we do with it and we
hope that it'll be kind of that pebble
in a pond that will have a ripple effect
so with that I'm gonna just shoot
through there we do have the website is
up
it's wwm alaykum th mah lah and calm it
hasn't been up before we literally just
launched it as I said the US the US GDC
tour is coming and on the 16th and any
of you are welcome to kind of just sneak
into that tour everybody else will be
paying for it not to us they're paying
for Greenville but happy to come or if
anybody has any other questions I've
been mentoring a lot of people at
Stanford and having them come and giving
them access to all the people on the
team so we're always happy to help
people from that perspective but with
that let's open it up for any questions
there there were a number of them on
here yeah you guys have some actually
while you're sort of reconsidering those
questions one thing I wanted to talk
about right away is that the cost
element because this does always come up
and it's embedded in a number of the
questions that you guys sent us and I
think it's really important to remember
so when we talk about green building as
I said at core we're talking about
change change of the status quo so you
go from product X to product Y and in
going from X to Y there are actually
three cost elements and they're often
lumped together in the case of green
buildings and I think that's wrong
headed and so like to take any
opportunity to debunk Billy Smith so the
first cost element is a learning curve
cost so I alerted write alluded to that
before
okay so learning curve so this doesn't
have anything to do with the building
right it enables the building to be
built
but fundamentally this cost should be
absorbed by the folks who are going to
benefit most from the learning which
isn't the homeowner it's all the
professionals who are building their
capacity as professionals to deliver a
more sophisticated relevant product so
this is not about the house
the second cost is the other one that
Linda referred to and I'd say call that
kind of the green increment or the bump
in quality where you start in saying
okay so let's do green well what does
that mean oh well maybe we should have a
more durable roof for example because
all of a sudden we learn through this
process that durability matters
longevity if you take a building and you
make it last a hundred years instead of
50 well then you've cut the material
impacts in half so that's an increment
and that's based on a decision to
produce a different product so you can't
really blame that on the house either
you've in effect changed your goal
you've shifted your goal so it's no
longer an added cost it simply becomes
part of the cost of this new product
that you've decided to create and the
third cost is administrative so this is
if you go after a certification of some
sort so there's some administrative
costs to doing that and actually I could
I could break this down a little bit to
and talk about a little bit about
quality management
- so administration yeah people have to
collect these to run programs and
quality management is something that's
almost entirely lacking in residential
construction and so there are people
through green programs who come and say
did you do all those things that you
said you were going to do and are they
actually functioning in the commercial
building world we call it commissioning
so of the three costs
this one is relatively minor doesn't add
a lot and it does have a lot of value
because it contributes to the
functioning of the project there are so
many buildings that are built never
function as they were intended it's
because nobody catches it this is
because you decided to create a
different product so that's going well
perhaps I will buy a beamer instead of a
Hyundai well that's not the beamers
fault right that's because you changed
your mind about what you're gonna spend
your money on and learning curve is
professional development so anyway
that's my little homily on costs
questions sorry and we have three
minutes that's terrible all right well
however much so what out what well
hopefully we covered we looked at your
questions ahead of time so you were
trying to hit them as we're going so
does anybody you guys have other
questions there were a lot of questions
about lead did any of you guys write
those questions are they burning yes
using like having the green buildings
using some of the appliances they were
talking what are you doing on the
marketing aspect how what are you doing
in terms of Lights burning this message
to people is it working are people
changing
but we're here yeah certainly yes I mean
we've helped a lot of people so for
instance we worked closely with the town
of Portola Valley town of Portola Valley
has now implemented very very stringent
Green Building Code so that helps and
but but they also have us as an example
to demonstrate to people that that isn't
the end of the world for people if they
if they do that because obviously
there'd be people that push back you
know it so it runs the gamut of where
people are on the spectrum in terms of
what they're looking for obviously for
the startups there's huge visibility for
the startups in that sense I mean we've
had a lot of press on the house because
it's won a lot of awards it and it's
gotten a lot of visibility from that
perspective and you know we continue to
do events and host events for people and
it could be everything from you know
doing music outreach and using the house
as an excuse for people to want to come
hear a concert to pay for music and
schools to sustainable Silicon Valley
wanting to use it specifically because
these five mayor's are working on Green
Building Code so so the the the outreach
is really getting the the website up so
that we can send people to it so I'm not
constantly having to write emails to
people but that's one but the two is
continuing to host events which we've
been more than willing to do the Solar
Decathlon team I mean there are 30 kids
on that team and we have opened our
entire team has been working with them
to kind of this the first time
Stanford's ever been accepted into the
Solar Decathlon so we're all very
excited for them so we hope it really
goes well you know I've been mentoring
we've been mentoring people in the
d.school
who have been looking at different
different places so it's it is kind of a
word-of-mouth because the challenges we
don't want it to be about us we want to
be about the house and obviously we have
a lot of connections but then it becomes
about us and it's that doesn't help that
doesn't promote so really what we're
trying to do is is do some outreach and
put it out there but then also have it
be kind of word-of-mouth as it as it
goes along and also having people come
and be in the space I mean honestly
truthfully this is a very hard class to
do it's very flat for us to come here
and have this conversation it is far
more fun and far more dynamic I will
just say to Leslie now to have you guys
there walking through the house seeing
the cistern climbing up the ladder into
the loft play loft and
being in Narnia which is what the girls
call it so I mean that's just it's just
a more dynamic 3d experience than
anything that we can convey here so I
think it's easier for you to walk away
interested excited inspired when you're
actually there and you're saying ooh you
know what I want to do this or I want to
tell somebody about this that it is when
you see it yeah you can't do it on the
16th I'm just saying that it that I
think that that we try as much as we can
to bring people to the site because we
think that tell that that actually tells
the story better than anything we had we
had the the it was a it was the site for
the American Society or sorry the
International Association of landscape
designers they do this they had their
international conference in San
Francisco and we had people who came up
said look I've been going to this
conference all over the world for 10
years I've never been someplace like
this so that's really what we hope is
people walk away excited
so was your question also more broadly
about green building as a whole
yeah yeah I mean that's an athlete and
those guys have been yeah I mean I'd say
I've been involved I've been in Green
Building pretty much 24/7 for the last
20 years and at the time it wasn't
called green building nobody knew what
it was and now it's pretty much a
household word right so I think we're
making good progress you had a question
the chemicals and different products you
used how in-depth did you look into the
solar panels because I know a lot of the
issue or a lot of things that I brought
up about solar panels is the embedded
energy that goes into making them was
that a factor in your analysis so that's
good well the embodied energy in solar
panels is generally paid back within the
first three years of operation so that's
that's the simple answer in terms of the
actual manufacturer the chemicals piece
they are what they are but as Linda said
at one point too energy Trump's you know
right now because climate change issues
are so paramount to the successful
proliferation or survival of our species
on this planet the planet will be fine
without us but we'd like to stick around
therefore we tend to prioritize energy
issues over others
when we have to make trade-offs and so
yes there are chemicals that are not
benign that are used in the manufacture
of photovoltaics but the net effect from
an energy perspective offsets so much
carbon that there's really no choice we
have to adopt Rumsey and renewable
energy was Rumsey who did y2e to and
have done a lot of the green buildings
on campus that's who are mechanical
there are MEP was Rumsey so and they
would just drilled it energy energy
energy it trumped everything house for a
little bit is there anything that went
exceptionally well or anything that you
would have changed now that you've lived
in it it's funny everybody asked that
question and I have to say so we've been
in it a year and there is right now
nothing that we would change it's
actually functioned phenomenally well
but that's why I think this concept of a
integrated design but also starting with
what your themes what we didn't start
with was we needed five bedrooms and two
bathrooms and of this and of that we
started with here are the five themes
that really we care about and if you
whatever you build if you look at those
and every single person on the team had
to read that and if they thought it was
too hokey then they didn't join the team
and and so I have to say it's really
functioned for for all the inhabitants
and for the people who have come it's
function really well I mean there's been
some commissioning things I mean one of
the things that I think is really really
important in anything you do I don't
care if you build a new product you
start a company but the minute you
launch you are not finished and so
that's one of the things that I think a
lot of people miss and I think that's
one of to me the biggest criticism I
have of LEED is that we got our LEED
Platinum highest rated house blah blah
blah the second we walked in the door
Living Building Challenge we can't even
start that process till now for a year
later until you've actually seen the
house work so I think there's a lot of
people who have the who potentially are
getting away with a lot of stuff because
nobody monitors it or maintains it and
you get to keep your status in
perpetuity without anybody ever coming
back and checking up and seeing if you
actually did we said you were going to
do or if it's performing yeah although
in the commercial realm you guys may
heard that there's lead e bomb existing
buildings operations and maintenance so
the vast majority of buildings that get
a LEED rating as a new building will
typically go on to get the e bomb rating
so they are addressing that for homes
it's a little bit harder because a
homeowner you know isn't selling
anything and the point of getting a
rating before there's operational data
is the rating originally the idea is to
help a builder sell a product so there
are folks like Linda and Paul who wanted
the rating for other reasons as she
described to you but from a mass-market
perspective it's all about you know
Better Homes and Gardens you know Green
Homes and Gardens seal of approval so
that as a buyer you can go oh this
building was built with a higher set of
considerations and so that precludes
having operational data that said there
are diagnostic and performance checks
that are done on all lead homes and it
was designed with that in mind you know
the understanding that we can't wait
until a year after it's been sold to put
a rating on it or it defeats the purpose
of the label their homes was actually
not designed for people like us it was
designed for KB homes and all the people
who are doing production home right
right now I'm gonna do it right because
those are the people who are producing
the vast majority of all homes and
getting them to do things better is
tremendously important you know the one
house demonstration project serves a
very different function in the ecosystem
of Green than those mass-market buyers
or producers rather yeah we'll stick and
we've got pictures and things like that
if anybody wants it and you can email us
through the website to if you have any
questions thank you
you